vice president dear margaritas
commissioner dia ilva honorable
ministers
members of the european parliament and
ladies and gentlemen
it has been 35 years since a number of
member states agreed
to remove border controls between
themselves
from five countries at the time the
schengen area grew to
26 counting 420 million
citizens a whole generation of europeans
grew up
with little memory of systematic
internal border checks
border checks have become anecdotal
many europeans organized their lives
around the freedoms
that schengen offers thanks to cheng and
companies transport goods around our
internal market
with just-in-time supply chains
thanks to schengen the internal border
regions
that cover 40 percent of eu's territory
could open up to their neighbors
thanks to schengen two million people
could find jobs as frontier workers
and most importantly people created
cross-border lings
and european families
the first month of the pandemic showed
us what happens
when schengen stops functioning europe
grinds to a halt
and it may sound like a paradox but this
experience
made me very confident in the future of
schengen
it is too precious for us all we will
not allow
it to fail but this does not mean that
we can take schengen for granted
recent years have strained shengen
between 2006 and 2014
over nine years internal border checks
were reintroduced
35 times but since 2015
in less than five years internal border
checks were reintroduced
205 times and this is a significant
increase
we need to understand the reasons behind
it and address them urgently
fact is that the challenges schengen
faces today
are not the same as 25 years ago we
should confront these challenges
head on i'm confident that we
can and must continue developing
schengen
while keeping its benefits
i see three areas of work
first an area without internal borders
needs a fully secure external border
no one should pass the border undetected
and any security risks must be
identified
this applies to eu and non-eu citizens
alike
and for this we need state-of-the-art
information systems
which we are already building this has
to happen
fast and we also need
good procedures like the screening
process
for people arriving irregularly this one
we proposed in the new pact on migration
and asylum
second we need to ensure security within
our common space close police
cooperation
as a rule not an exception
for example better and faster exchange
of data such as fingerprints of suspects
or a stronger role for europol
and third schengen needs better
governance
we need to work on our system of
evaluation and monitoring
we have to be fully confident about the
application of rules
everywhere in europe and i believe
we need a better common political
steering
of schengen with the european parliament
and the member states
the reason why we organized today's
schengen forum
is to hold a discussion on a way forward
i would like a pragmatic and operational
debate
that we can use to inform the schengen
strategy
that we will put forward in may next
year
but let me also be clear about an
important issue
as we develop schengen we cannot
compromise on the fundamentals
any internal border checks must be a
last resort
and we need to work in very close
coordination
europeans have grown to rely on schengen
today it is essential for our economy
and for our way of life
and we all have a responsibility to make
it
work thank you very much